in this last capsule on the
first round logic we will see
some last concepts that are
important the logic of the first round
so far so office that I have
describes this is the general principle of
proof by resolution without
necessarily lobry sure comment this
that we print as input
automation of the prep resolution in
do we can imagine we could
solve this problem the letter the
heuristic search
for example makes it our function
purpose that would correspond to reaching a
state that contains an empty clause in
what if our state makes both of them
initials it would consist of our base
of knowledge and then the application
of the resolution rule that allows
to add formulas to our database
knowledge this would correspond to
make a transition
and here we will try to reach a goal that
is to reach a state that
contains the rhythm clause and our
office transition function that
could match all
possible applications to rick's
resolution a given state and so we
would not be able to demonstrate
thing if in fact after exploring
all the giraffe could not find
a state that reaches the goal function so
we could imagine a way of
solve the problem or automated the
proof by resolution with research
heuristic searching in a serious
I'm not going to the edges and there on by
against you can go see the section
9 points 5.6 for in the book of
energetic resources to learn
a little more on the subject a few
applications of automation of
first run logic we can do the
computer software audit
so when it's the basis of
art knowledge contained any
information on the effects of each
instruction in the program that their
conditions to be executed and the
kind of question we could ask
that's what we can get to
a state of the program that corresponds to a
any bug or problem of
security and so once we have
formulated all the effects of each
instruction of our program with these
conditions of execution in our base
of knowledge that can be rephrased
problem of finding a bug
basically a problem of maybe
of security compared to our
program like a rocket
in first order logic we can even
defeat the synthesis of
software that is, we would formulate
a question of this kind is what exists
a program that would allow
meet a certain specifications
the application the support the not rendered of the
first-order logic
however, it is probably the
expert systems where we have an expert who
will put in the bottom all his
knowledge his expertise under a
form
logical so that's going to be the basis of
knowledge and one could do
among other things the medical diagnosis or
given a patient's symptoms
precise to determine what is the key
the disease behind these symptoms then
what are the what is the treatment the
more appropriate and so we had a
formulation in the form of logic of
first order of all his
knowledge the bridge could make some
queries and finally simulate the
reasoning of an expert in by
to his expertise and one can even
to prove theorems
automated mathematics I invite you
to look in the book where we discuss
a bit of what kind of theorems have
already been shown like that but it's
something lucky that is possible to
do when automating the
logical reasoning with the logic of
first rank and besides also in the
book we are going to speak just for
some mathematical interests we have
need them other types of logic
there are logic a little more complex
that first-rate logic of which it is
things that are discussed in the
book in logic of the first add on
normally includes the notion of equality
which we denote there with the equal symbol and
it's actually a notion that we do not have
not spoken in the previous capsules
but a way of managing equality in
the
the context we've seen up to
now with our definition of the
syntax of the first rank logic
actually wants to add several
formulas that would describe equality so
which will represent among others
symmetry properties transitivity of
equality and at that moment adding
these formulas there we will be able to
manage the notion of equality between
different constant that could
refer to the same objects and apply the
proof by resolution that we saw in
the president capsules there are
other ways of managing equality then
for that I invite you to watch the
section 9 points 5.5 of the milk of the soul
angry and did in practice in
automated logic systems
often in fact we avoid having to manage
equality by doing away with
unique or unique English names
nielsen
this provision did it she says that
two constants that have a symbol
different necessarily correspond
different entity entities so in
other words and usefully it wants you
to say that we will never designate the same
person or the same object under two names
different symbols so in this case
as simple as we do not really have to
manage the equality between terms that
are different another guess
which is sometimes done in logic
from the first we suppose we call
that the open domain solution what
it actually means that there is no
no known limits on the set
objects that are modeled in our
knowledge base what that wants
to say concretely is that we can not
replace universal quantification
like here for all x we ​​could not
replace the use of the
universal quantification by a
very long conjunction or in this
example if for all x
nobody is mere mortal x
can not replace it with a list of
formula one would have nobody x implies
mortal x for all values
possible of x
and the reason we can do
it does not write limit on all
terms of the constants which to which
could reference
exit so that's the guess of the
open domain and there are some
logic reasoning software that will
to make rather a guess
closed domain because if it takes
explicitly say what is the whole
objects of my world that I model
with with the logic of first rank and
in this case we could use
a long, exhaustive conjunction that
involves all the objects for that it's
another way to actually model
or add knowledge
involving universal quantification
but explicitly it would be
possible to do south in a field
closed and we can do the same
reasoning for quantification
existential another important concept
logical and it's a girl guess
logical base pts effect this first
round this is called the position
of an open world in what it wants
to say concretely is that if I have
learned from kpd x that is not part of
the vast knowledge base of
formula but it does not imply
necessarily that his contract his
negation is going to be true ok so if i have
not put an acquaintance or a formula
as explicitly true in my base of
knowledge a little say that the
contrary is true so it means that
negation against some
software that logical reasoning
that they are going to do just this
guess there then we'll talk about a
closed domain ie question nos
pool comics in something is
true its opposite your cold so
prologue is an example of a language of
logical programming that allows
to automate logical reasoning
who does these three positions
there of which we have just spoken not unique
closed domain then a closed world and
it's actually it's potion water
are quite common and we make them
reference to his kits there
as being on bail of the
semantic of tons passes
so if in future reading on the
logical provence you see these
terms there you will be a little more to what
it corresponds among other ideas of
concepts that are often used in
the practical deployment laws of the
first logical logic of the canton
want automated in a system
data processing
finally one thing I did not talk about
again it's actually in my base of
initial knowledge so at the very beginning
before we start trying to
demonstrate something we had
explicitly we must assume that there
no contradiction
so for example we do not have in our
knowledge base predicts copy
of x and his negation because
actually on my opinion that would be
easy to use art and
resolutions to arrive immediately
the empty clause for any
any formula that
would try closely 10 is actually the
problem of saying if a conjunction of
several clauses a conjunction of
several shots I can never between
that is, there is essentially
two contradictions this problem which
knew about computer in time the
problem of satisfying it so
say if we have a conjunction clause that
can never be and we'll say it's
a klose conjunction that is not
satisfactory and the problem of me
answer is like answer to this
question there pardon that's what we
call the problem of the satisfied
militating and in fact it's a problem that
has been shown to be a problem
mt complete what it was a little
accomplice and we do not know
of algorithms that a ponoma complexity
polynomial that can respond to this
problem
it's actually the problem of city
reliability this is the first problem that
has been shown to be a tool
complete and after an instance of this
problem there that the problem 3 sat who
is very well known in computer science more than
you may see NATO
in other courses you go
follow the computer and that it comes
to determine a conjunction of lawn
of literal troyes specifically so
with the constraint that we are king the
potting soil in every clause in my
conjunction then the palace of herminis
a conjunction clause of three liberals
is satisfying it's a problem that
know the problem 3sat so this is a
instance of the segregated premium so empowered
unfortunately being a base of
knowledge we have developed is
it is difficult to
to say is there a competition
beats so be careful
when we list our database
knowledge in an application
practice to make sure not to introduce
contradictions which unfortunately
there is not an algorithm that in
all cases in general vote to
be effective in identifying her so
you have to prove your involvement
aude to the development of a database of
knowledge in logic of the first
twenty